- So, your new season
of "Vanderpump Rules",
what's going on?
What's a tease for us?
- It was so complicated, you know,
and it kind of blew up
out of the stratosphere.
I mean, it was just so crazy.
It was a lot of bad
behavior the season before.
- Yeah.
- And we tried to sort it out,
but we'd stopped filming
when it was all exposed.
So, we need this season, this
season feels very different
to any other season, to sort it out.
And as the kind of matriarch,
do you ever watch the show?
You're looking at me like, maybe you do.
- No, I'm just fascinated
by everything you do.
I'm like, what don't you do?
It's insane.
- Oh, there's a couple of
things, ask my husband.
(audience laughs)
- Stop it.
(audience clapping)
- It's the British humor.
- I have so many jokes.
They're so wasted right now.
God, I wish this was a nighttime show.
Well, we need another commercial break.
Everybody watch "Vanderpump
Rules" Tuesdays on Bravo
and streaming on Peacock.